the difference
well there's a lot of difference
I believe in
Jiu Jitsu especially in the garden you
can't stay in midrange yeah I don't want
to cover it I guess like if I'm in the
standing position
I want to cover like this my head is off
the ground my muscle and of my abdominal
are contracted so it's possible for you
to damage here but because I'm
contracted
less likely so I want to focus all the
protection on my head you're okay with
this yeah it's okay it's okay but I want
to be here so there's a gap where I can
see you here if I'm here it's not as
efficient because you can go on the side
and it's easy for you to grab grab my
wrist put it down and here yeah if I'm
here it's harder for you to control my
arm if you want to grab it it's hard for
you to grab so that's the first thing
another thing if your handers are here
I want to take away your hand on me I
want to fool you pull you to me I want
to control your head and your hand and
from there there's a menu option I like
to take the clamp because it controls
your elevation and you can't hit me it's
either I'm very close to you or
I'm very far are you trying to get up
I'm very far yeah if I can't get it up
no problem I'm using my leg to push you
away or I can use the tip of my tweet to
create distance
so you need to be aware that I can kick
you in the head too so it's either very
close or very far over on top on top
yeah so if I'm On Top the best position
for me to be
ultimately is
not even Mount is to have your back
left you to the floor
from this position because now you
cannot hit me I can't hit you and I can
either knock you out or submit you this
is the worst Mount is
the second best because I'm having a lot
of control Mount and also with my knees
under your armpit the worst would be in
your garden so it's not as bad as if you
would be in a jiu jitsu competition
because of that the gravity on my side
but if I'm here I need to respect three
rules I never want
you to put my hands on the floor and go
on submission all kinds of things you
can very easily wrap my arm and wrap my
head close the distance and now it's a
thing
so nowhere another floor
I don't want you to have your head
higher than my head because if your head
is iron in my head you have a guillotine
it's very hard for me to control and do
anything for you if
my head is is lower than your head and
another thing
the third thing is I don't want to let
you take an angle of me so if you take
an angle to do a GG Academy you see you
need to take an angle so if I take away
that angle
I kill your reference so my hands always
on you never on the floor are you
kidding are you trying to hit a little
bit yeah I can hit them at the same time
if you try to raise your head up
I don't accept that in my other eye if
you try to take an angle
I put you back in life
so if I respect these three rules as I'm
as I'm respecting this rule I can cause
damage even if I'm in the garbage my
goal is always eventually to pass a
guard get to a more dominant position I
love it it's a
shell that's that's what it is about